الكلمه لك
سيدي
سيدتي الرئيسه الاعضاء الموقر للمحكمه انه
فخر وشرف ان اقف امامكم اليوم بالنيابه عن
دوله جنوب افريقيا اود ان اعبر عن امتناني
للمحكمه الموقره على عقد هذه الجلسه وفي
اسرع وقت ممكن من اجل النظر في طلب جنوب
افريقيا بفرض التدابير مؤقته
وفي طلبنا وطلب جنوب افريقيا قد لاحظت
النكبه المستمره للشعب
الفلسطيني عبر الاستعمار الاسرائيلي منذ
عام 1948 والذي قام بطريقه ممنهجه
في تشريد وشرد وتقسيم الشعب الفلسطيني
وحرمانهم بشكل متعمد من حقوقهم المتعارف
عليها دوليا على راسه حق تقرير المصير
وحقهم ايضا المشروع عليه
عوده اللاجئين الى قراهم ومدنهم الى ما هو
يسمى باسرائيل الان كما ايضا اسرائيل
ونظامهم ايضا بقوانينه التمييز العنصري
ممارساتهم التي سممت من اجل فرض الهيمنه
واخضاع الشعب الفلسطيني للتمييز العنصري
على كلا طرفي الخط الاخضر عقود من الافلات
من
العقاب وفي انتهاكات ممنهجه لحقوق الانسان
جرات اسرائيل اتت اسرائيل الجراه في
التكرار وتكثيف جرائمها الدوليه في فلسطين
ومنذ البدايه جنوب افريقيا تدرك بان هذه
الاعمال الاباده الجماعيه التي ترتكبها
دوله اسرائيل
وهي مرافقه
ل الاعمال الغير قانونيه ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني منذ العام
1948 ان الطلب يتعلق بال الاباده الجماعيه
وفي سياقها الاوسع ل 75 عاما من الفصل
العنصري الاسرائيلي و احتلال و1 عاما من
الحصار على قطاع غزه حصار بحد ذاته وصف من
قبل
الامين من مسؤولين الامميين بان غزه هي
عباره
عن مكان قتل للفلسطينيين
وجنه لازاله التمييز العنصري
وتحذيراتها
في 21 من ديسمبر بان خطاب الكراهيه
والتمييز موجه وجه ضد الفلسطينيه والذي
سبب بعث قلق كبيره ضد اسرائيل والتزاماتها
والتزام اخرى في في ارتكاب بادئ الجماعيه
في غزه في هذا
الصباح كان هنالك عده تنبيهات بما في
ذلك المقرر العام للامم المتحده في تقرير
73 حول فشل النظام الدولي للتحرك لمنع
اباده جماعيه تتكشف في غزه اليوم تنضم
للمحكمه ينضم للمحكمه ممثل للدوله
الفلسطينيه فلسطينيون عملوا فلسطين عمل في
مجال حقوق الانسان بما في ذلك مقيمين ايضا
مقيمين في غزه كانوا هنالك منذ
ايام
مستقبلهم
ومستقبل اخوتهم الفلسطينين الذين يزالون
موجودين في غزه يعتمدوا على قرار الذي س
تطلقه هذه المحكمه